hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the uh 2022
phoenix candidates tournament it's
rehearsal versus young
uh this is round eight and uh uh both
rapport and duda are having pretty much
the identical tournament uh they both
drew all of their games except the one
uh against the ani polish both of them
lost their game tayani pomeshi uh
rapport in the in round seven we've
covered that game uh and now they are
playing against each other so both of
them really really want a win for this
uh uh second half of the of defeating
candidates tournament and that can only
benefit us the players
and maybe one of them you know if if one
of them actually wins the game uh so
before we check it out
here is a nice photo before the game you
can see that they are preparing to make
moves uh and one of the questions that
was asked that um uh
rapport was uh uh what color is his suit
is it a red suit is it a pink suit or is
it a salmon color suit now i'm not a
color expert and uh
like you know
i i really don't know my way around
colors uh so if any of you know what
color this could be you know dimension
in the comments says it is it is a very
interesting color
uh so uh yeah i just thought i'd mention
that and also rapper said that his wife
wanted him to wear it uh in the previous
game now the one against the annie
palmer but he said that it's better that
he didn't you know the way he played
that it would only do the suit a great
injustice or or something like that uh
but yeah let's dive straight into it
rapport has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 we have e5 by duda knight
to f3 knight to c6 and now sorry knight
to c6 knights to f6 going for the petra
of defense uh and uh well rapport is not
interested in allowing dude some sort of
a quick draw in the petrov he declines
it and he plays knight to c3 he goes for
the three nights game which usually
means a four nights game so knight to c6
and now how do you look for chances in a
in an opening that is so old and so
analyzed that pretty much everyone knows
everything about it well you don't play
any of the main lines you don't play you
don't play d for bishop c for bishop b5
but you play g3 so we're going to
fiancato the light square bishop and
it's going to be
uh it's going to be a slow game uh but
uh you know we're not allowing duda to
just get a draw with the black pieces
here so bishop to c5 bishop to g2 and
now d6 we have pawn to d3 and now uh you
could just castle automatically but then
you might run into knight a4 and you
really don't want to allow white to grab
this bishop this is a beautiful bishop
occupying a beautiful diagonal so first
we're going to play a5 we make room for
the bishop a6 is much more common a5 is
in fact very very rare
but okay we have castles now and now
comes a ponte h6 there are some games
where castles was played also bishop to
e60 is a known move uh but dude as h6 is
a new move so already as of move seven
we have a completely new game uh where
uh where do the surprises are rapport i
guess it's not much of a surprise if if
you want it um
i guess he he said to himself if if you
know a petrov arises on the board i'm
gonna go for the four nights and i have
to be ready for for such moves so okay
pawn to b3 now keeping around this pawn
not allowing it to go any further with
a4 now and you also could fianchetto the
dark square bishop as well uh but all
depends on what to do the place so
castles with h3 uh freeing up this h2
square for the king you do not want the
king on this diagonal and not knight to
d4 just uh improving the position
preparing pawn to c6 later on you're
going to play rook e8 to defend the e5
pawn hopefully push d5 at some point so
duda is having a
an absolute um you know
super enjoyable game uh bishop to e3 uh
nicely developing and the c6 now we have
king to h2 and rook to e8 so uh duda is
just uh waiting to see what robert will
do but there really isn't all that much
to do here we have pawn to a3 and now
duda goes for some trades knight
captures queen captures and the bishop
captures an e3 and here
if you
if you you know wanted to play a
principled game or if you even ask the
engine what should we play here then
queen captures an e3 is the move you
play yeah you you know you keep your
pawn structure intact and you look for
some chances uh you know elsewhere but
then black strikes in the center with d5
and so on but
uh you know a long long time ago humans
realized that uh well pretty much intact
pawn structures seldom present winning
chances and he goes for f captures on e3
he doubles his pawn structure here but
he opens up the df file to be used for
attacking purposes and okay judas is not
a problem we have pawn to b5 and here
the rapper goes for g4
now he's saying that he wants to play
queen to g3 and push g5 and start an
attack against duda's king luda says all
right this is i mean if this was good
everyone would be playing it we have
rooked a7 guarding that f7 pawn and
queen to g3 now we have h5 and not
allowing uh well just uh you know uh
dude uh rapper to start attacking so h5
and the idea is that if you capture on
h5 yes you open up the g file but after
knight captures on h5 it's uh not all
that great for example queen goes here
we're going to play g6 defend our knight
the rook defends f7 everything is nicely
defended and it would be duda who is
better here so instead we have g5 and
now duda doesn't want to allow knight h7
and h4 he doesn't want to see this on
the board so he sacrifices a pawn here
after g5 he plays h4 first so the queen
captures and the h
pawn will not be able to occupy the h4
square so quickly so queen to h4
knight to h7 now going after the
g5 pawn and now queen back to g3 rapport
is now ready to play h4 and do that will
of course capture on g5 now the question
is what will do the capture with and the
uh the safe option is queen captures on
g5 interestingly this was not played in
the game point is that after captures
captures and h4 let's say we're gonna
put the knight to e6 and you know it's
it's it's a game uh black has nothing to
worry about if anything black is better
here
but uh after knight captures on g5 which
is also perfectly fine it is uh well the
queens are still on the board and it is
a white who is kind of attacking here so
h4 knights the h7 and now bishop to h3
opening up the g file for the white rook
uh do the capture sun h3 and now you
don't want to capture right away if you
capture right away then rookie 6 and
after rook g1 the rook is in time to
stop checkmate and uh again black is
just better here so instead rook to g1
right away we reach the position from
the thumbnail we're going to recapture
the bishop but we are now threatening
checkmate here and the question is how
can do that defend
the most precise way to defend is just
g6 obviously the most boring one but the
most precise and after the bishop is
captured we're going to put the knight
in f6 uh guard the h5 square and there
is nothing white can do to to break
through this position uh however after
rook to g1 duda had a different plan he
played knight to g5 now he defends the
bishop and he wants uh at upper to play
h captures and g5 which will close the g
file now
uh true as that may be uh it will close
the g file but it will open up the h
file so here h captures on g5 bishop
back to c8 and now comes rook to g2 uh
you might also consider king g2 with
ideas of just doubling up on the h file
but then queen d7 and you are not in
time to double up here black will be
able to trade queens here so rook the g2
uh we have rook 8 to e7 uh here instead
of rocate the e7 f6 is the mo is the way
to go but it's uh you know who who plays
f6 here it's such an unnatural move to
make uh the problem is that this is
nothing because you just capture back
and the rook and queen guard the g7 if
you play g6 then king f8 we start
marching our king over to the queen side
uh but after rook eight to e7 this
allows rapport a very important uh move
and that is queen to f3 now he has all
sorts of ideas he can bring the rook to
f1 he can bring the rook to h1 he can
put pressure on f7 in the future he can
you know shift the queen to h5 bring the
rook to h1 play king g1 put pressure on
the h file and duda is is pretty much
without without ideas here again f6 is
the way to go but here duda plays g6 and
now rapport has all the time in the
world we have rook to h1
uh f5 by duda and now king the g1 we
have pawned the b4 attacking the knight
and now e captures on f5 uh rapper
sacrifices the knight here but it's not
really a sacrifice the knight cannot be
captured if you capture the knight f
captures on g6 and there's no defense
here you're just going to play queen h5
and check made the black king there
it's unstoppable so instead we have g
captures on f5 and now rapport played
knight to e4 and it was in this position
on move 29 that young [ __ ] of duda
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
so really really uh really an impressive
game by by both of them but rapport
decided that even though
he lost his game to nipple in the
previous round he's going to play an
attacking game he he played it very
slowly and this is uh how pretty much
all the all the great players who um you
know uh have a must win a game or it's a
must-win situation say that you want to
keep the game uh you know you don't want
to trade too many pieces you want to
keep your options open you just want to
play a nice game and that's basically
that basically means you know play a
slow opening you know fiance to your
bishops and so so on uh and you know
opportunities will present themselves
and here you resign because if you
capture the knight again uh just queen
h5 and that's it if you play rook g7 or
something to try and you know escort the
king all the way to the queen side we
don't care g6 and if king f8 we're gonna
play queen h8 to check rook to g8 now
rook f2 check king the e7 and it's a
mating attack queen h6 check king to e6
and now queen to f7 will be checkmate or
you know any of the other lines also uh
ending checkmate and after knight to e4
even if you don't capture the knight
what else can you play you can play king
g7 or something try to you know bring
the rooks into the game now we play rook
gta h2 and after rook to g8 we're going
to play rook to h6 so absolutely
everything is winning here we're just
going after the d6 pawn and there's no
good way
there's no good way to tackle this uh
it's it's just a completely winning
winning position if bishop to e6
blocking the
path to the d6 pawn we can even play
knight to f6 and now just i mean that
there's no move you can make here
whatever you play is just silly the the
rook is hanging rook the h7 is coming
it's just uh
[Music]
there's no movie you can even try here
so after 94 duda is i'm sure very
disgusted with his position and he
resigns which means that rapport grabs
his first point in the feeder candidates
tournament and now for the standings as
i know you guys are
very very much interested in this uh
here are the standings after uh eight
rounds of defeating candidates
tournament janiponishi is leading with a
full point lead six points ahead of
fabiana corona with five points then
hikaru nakamura with four and a half and
then rapport with four points after
getting his uh first win then we have
dingler and yongshi to do that
uh who are uh the the other half of the
standings and you can see that uh uh
none of them uh have won a single game
which is pretty tough for a candidate
tournament you have to you know win at
least one you know for the for the ball
to start rolling but uh for them uh so
far not not
not much is happening uh but you can see
how impressive nippo is uh with four
wins four incredible wins and four draws
that's i mean incredible he if he
continues uh you know winning games like
this he might even finish the candidates
tournament uh as a 2800 player
uh but yeah fobby trailing by a full
point uh today we have the clash fobby
versus nepo which is of course probably
the one that will decide the candidates
tournament but you know it's still early
anything can still happen you know no
one is saying that nepal can't lose the
next two games or that fabi can't lose
the next two games so you know anything
can still happen
and usually when anything can happen it
does happen uh so yeah once again i hope
you guys enjoyed it and that you were uh
you know uh
able to figure out what color rapper
suit is uh so you know be sure to
mention that in the comments as well uh
i would like to thank david kimura and
uh i would like to thank stephen mcneil
be the the uh is the one uh daniel
schmidt and ultimate poker coaching for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day